[Music]
grandchildren it's faster Kris Jenner is
getting her growing family in the
Christmas spirit with her extravagant
decor family's everything so that comes
first Kim Kardashian gave her followers
and kids north and Saint West a grand
tour of her mom's house for the holidays
Thursday night so my favorite thing to
do is drive around in the town and show
my kids all the Christmas tree lights
they haven't seen my mom's house
decorated yet she did a rainbow fan
inside Chris kept the colorful theme
going with reindeers for lavish
Christmas trees and a giant polar bear
statue but of course North wanted to be
the center of attention so she did it
differently this year she used to have a
huge tree okay one sec she used to do a
huge tree but now she's just doing for
smaller trees all in rainbow really
classic and pretty the Kardashian crew
have already dropped some of their denim
themed Christmas card photos Kim told et
it's a test she will never take on in
the future just to wrangle every single
family member was so exhausting I've
never in my life just I thought it would
be really easy it was it was really
tough but it'll be a good one this year
I think our best yet really yeah
[Music]
you